اولا يا عزيزي هي كانت
تاجت تجربه بالنسبه لي انا اعشق باريس
وعشت فيها اكثر مما عشت في قريتي وبالتالي
حينما تقاعدت من جامعه
اليمامه اربع سنوات وعرض علي
الموقع او المنصب شعرت بانني محظوظ يعني
وبالتالي
ذهبت بنوع من انواع الحماس ولكن ارهانات
رهانات محدده لان الفرص وهذا ما ذكرته
عليه باستمرار الفرصه ليست سعيده او شقيه
الا بحسب ما تحولها انت الى رهان وتحاول
ان تكسره وبالتالي سافرت
في ذهني انه انا اعرف شكل رئيس المعهد من
فتره طويله وذكرت التفاصيل هذه المعرفه
وكنت اتوقع انه الموضوع الي او بشكل او
باخر يعني سهل جدا
وحينما
التقيتهم مره مره اخرى ادركت ادركت انه
كان يخفي غير غير ما يظهر لانه المملكه
للامانه اخذت
حصتها من المنصب مع الاستاذ منى زندار
بقيه سنه او فتره ونصف يعني حوالي اربع
سنوات ونص وبالتالي المملكه كانت قانونيا
ليس ليس لها سوى سنه ونصف
انا راح انت على انه سنه ونص لا يمكن اقبل
المنصب واتفقنا على ثلاث سنوات لكن اكتشفت
انه حتى هذا التنازل لم يكن
لم يكن مقنعا له وبالتالي شعرت انه يلعب
لعبه معينه لعبه مكر فقلت لابد ان ناتي من
فوق يعني لابد يكون في مكر وبدات اكشف
الاوراق للسفر وش كان منطقة دكتور كان في
اعتقادي انه كان لديه مرشح عربي اخر وانه
كان فيه وعد من الملك عبد الله رحمه الله
بمبلغ معين دعم المعهد قبل قبلي وقبل اظن
المناخه زندار حتى وكان يريد ان يحصل عليه
ويقول انتم قانونيين اخذتم حصتكم وانتهى
الموضوع
فحينما عرضت الموضوع على
المعادن الاستاذ خالد العنقري وهو
يعني من هو في الخبره والتجربه ولكن ايضا
كان في نوع من انواع العلاقه الحميمه لا
اقول الصداقه لكن علاقه حميمه بيني وبينه
من فتره معينه
فيبدو انه حسمها بطريقه
جيده
وغريب جدا انه بعد ما مره ثلاث سنوات اصر
جاك لاند قبل غيره على ان يمدد لي
وفي الفتره الثانيه قبيل سفري باسابيع
وبيوم واحد كان يرسل لي كل مره شخص لكي
امدد الفتره الثالثه يعني كان بامكاني ان
اقضي تسع سنوات في المعهد لماذا اظنه
اكتشف ان
هذا المرشح الذي لم يكن مرضيا عنه في
البدايه عمل شيئا نوعيه للمعهد هذا مارجوه
علي الحاله هي المساله انه عمل شيء ولا
على انه الدعم حيستمر لم لم تتبرع المملكه
بعدها باي شيء من بعد ما من بعد الخمسه
مليون لم يكن هناك اي اي الفتره الاولى
الفتره الاولى من ايام الملك عبد الله لكن
ايضا كان عندنا معرض العلا وكان في بعض
التعاون لكن اعتقد انه
حسن الحظ وبالفرع شركات
مثمره بناءه جاده مع جيلك فيصل في الرياض
مع محمد شحرور
اظنني استطعت ان
اقدم شيء نوعي للمعهد وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بجنوب المتوسط بالشركه العربي للامانه
ورجل سياسي من الطراز الاول لكن استاذ
جامعي ومثقف كبير وبالتالي ادرك ان ان
هناك شيء جديد
ربما يتطور وانا لو لو بقيت
وكان عندي دعم بالتاكيد سيحضر المعهد في
العالم العربي اكثر واكثر لكن انا وصلت
الى مرحله التشبع جمالي من باريس
وتشبع من المعهد وفي لحظه من اللحظات انا
اعتقد الانسان الذي يتمتع بقدر من الحكمه
انه اذا لم يعد لديه اضافات نوعيه عليه ان
ينسحبه وهو في الذره والا والا يصبح مثل
زعماء العالم الثالث يظل الواحد الى ان
يخرب كل ما بناته والحياه